there are it's fantastic to see you
tonight at the premiere for Dracula and
tell what you're looking forward to I'm
really looking forward to seeing the
film after such a long way you know it's
gonna be great to get in there and
finally see it now we haven't seen you
for a little while on Game of Thrones
but have you been enjoying the show
yourself I'm not actually allowed to
watch the show so you're gonna have to
ask my mom if I could start watching it
I get to see some of my scenes but you
know it's all Freddie you know 18 so
yeah what's your favorite scene that you
see any of your own so far I think it
has to be the brown leaving scene I
think it was great seeing I really got a
chance to sort of show how I can act
would you like him to come back in and
how would you like him to come back in
well I'd like him to come back to brown
and you know sort of the whole family's
come back together again which would be
great but you never know do you like the
fantasy kind of dragons and the White
Walkers
yeah well it's great that it has that
sort of you know it has dragons and
magic and all these sort of different
things yes so it's great it's a great
show ready what's it been like working
with when you were working with Isaac
and Kristian Nairn across Berlin there
tonight Anna yeah they're all great
people yeah
Christian's massive and he's such a
great fellow he's like a PFG you know
and I use ik you know it's great to have
sort of had another child there to work
with natalie is amazing as well we're
not gonna see any brand or Hodor in
Stevens by Vivint old what do you think
of that
it's it's come as a surprise I haven't
heard about that yet but you know
hopefully they'll come back a stronger
character I think the writers already
know what they're doing
you